salve questo è struttura no non è vero
questo e mostarda maino tubi voglio
dimostrare veramente soltanto tu che
parli davanti uno sfondo bianco si è tra
l'altro ne approfitto per ringraziarli
tutti i commenti strappalacrime
torcibudella che mi avete mandato ed ho
solo detto che avrei smesso le
recensioni pensa se fosse morto ma non
siamo qui a parlare della mia vita ho
già fatto due video così
prendetelo per colle arriva altrimenti
non ne usciamo vivi abbiamo capito è
triste non serve mettere ogni volta una
musichetta alla fine sdolcinata col
piano ok ma sono qui per parlarvi di un
film che ho visto fuga di cervelli
il film del web come lo soprannominato
io molti prima di me hanno visto il film
e ne hanno già parlato qui su youtube
per esempio victor l'asl 88 vi metto il
link della sua recensione nelle info e
tutti incredibilmente ne hanno parlato
male però come io dico sempre bisogna
testare con mano per capire se una cosa
è bella o no è inutile andare ad
ascoltare prima gli altri quindi ho
cercato di guadare il film senza i tre
concetti liberandomi la testa di tutte
le cose che avevo sentito per la più
grande merda che io abbia mai visto in
vita mia e chi mi segue da un po sa che
le ho visto abbastanza è il peggior film
italiano che potesse mai esistere sulla
faccia della terra
vi spiego il perché quando primo detto
che è un film del web e perché i suoi
protagonisti sono del web
i protagonisti sono il primo youtuber
che è diventato famoso con gli scherzi
telefonici frank matano il primo
youtuber che è diventato famoso per
essere a drag queen we move il primo
youtuber che ha fatto l'inverso prima
vado a lavorare in tv poi pensa olio di
e nessuno sa chi cazzo sono mettiamoci a
fare di doppiaggi su youtube
paolo ruffini e due tra i peggiori
comici di colorado non è che loro sono i
peggiori in particolare e che colorado è
una merda in generale quindi chiunque
fosse uscito sarebbe stato la merda
comunque i panpers quale la sinossi di
questo film c'è questo gruppo di amici
caratterizzati in modo molto molto
specifico l'idiota l'idiota l'idiota
l'idea de guglielmo ha proprio a quella
scrittura quasi kubrickiana l'idiota
nerd
il gruppo è innamorato di una ragazza
che cerca in tutti i modi di conquistare
ma questa ragazza con una borsa di
studio deve partire ad oxford e anche
lui decide di partire ad oxford nysje ma
tutta la mandria di idioti e guglielmo
temi poi succedono proprie finché poi
nardone non riesce a conquistare sta
benedetta ragazza e vissero tutti felici
e contenti tranne chi è andato a vedere
film recensioni fa si parla di tre a
quattro anni fa dissi una cosa molto
particolare per quanto riguarda i film
comici secondo voi cosa c'è di peggio di
un brutto film un film comico che non fa
è esatto prendete quella specifica frase
applicata era per 100.000 questo fin qua
sembra uno di quei filmacci da quattro
soldi che prende a piene mani da film di
maggior successo inspiegabilmente tipo
american pie
ma in realtà è un remake o scusate
remake di un film spagnolo che io non
l'ho visto perché non me ne frega ma
proprio tutta la ii e magari qualcuno di
voi lo sa è la merda pure quello per
sapere no perché si spiegherebbero molte
cose
il film non fa mai ridere ci prova e ci
riprova con intuizioni geniali quali la
scorreggia prove in che dimentica
addirittura aldo giovanni giacomo hanno
detto mica se l'avessimo saputo noire
voglio i soldi o battute come ma è così
che si fanno le seghe mentali colleghi
che lui e una testa di cazzo
oppure grandi classici dell'umorismo
all'italiana come ieri qualcuno ci ha
chiamato chi sto cazzo ma vi e volete
sapere quel punto forte è una commedia
fatta di equivoci o milo 0 l'uruguay ho
mai visto una cosa del genere a parte
tutti i cinepanettoni usciti dagli anni
90 fino ad oggi però come l'avesse fatto
voi non ha mai fatto nessuno e film tra
l'altro si basa su una delle più grandi
puttanate che io abbia mai visto i
recenti anni
la trama come ho detto è abbastanza
semplice ragazzo che vuole conquistare
la ragazza quella parte allora loro la
seguono e lui la conquista il problema è
che lei sin dall'inizio del film è
innamorata di lui e tutto il film si
appoggia sul fatto che i suoi amici gli
amici di lui lì con serino che cazzo
fare per conquistarla ma lei innamorata
di lui ho capito che lei è andata a
oxford ok tu l'hai seguita li poteva
durare sette minuti 7 compri i titoli di
coda
non so come dirtelo sono innamorato di
te anche io stupidotto ieri andiamo a
fare sesso come dei babbuini ma no
altrimenti non ce lo passano un film di
7 minuti
spendiamo un'ora e quaranta della vita
delle persone che ci stanno guardando
per fare nulla non c'è neanche la morale
finale almeno nei film di merda una
morale c'è una roba tipo lei non vuole
stare con un nerd ma poi scopri che il
nerd in realtà è una persona come le
altre anzi no anche meglio dei bulli che
di solito frequenta e allora sorpassa
l'aspetto per mettersi con la
personalità
no perché lei già innamorata di lui non
avendo il film ed è questo il motivo per
cui per me fuga di cervelli è il più
grande disastro che mai sarebbe potuto
arrivare sugli schermi non perché un
film di merda ma perché un film di merda
che è uscito da gente che dal web ha
fatto la sua fortuna che abbiamo
frank ma porca di una [ __ ] nei film
tu sei matto lo dico con il cuore
decente non nel senso che fa ridere
perché non fa ridere 8 ottimismo no può
farlo anche mia nonna quella parte lì ed
è morta per dire no tu sei molto
naturale
hai dei tempi comici che sono molto
buoni il problema aggiunge quando devi
dire puttanate
puoi essere uno dei più grandi attori
dell'universo però 16 cagate cagate
rimangono quindi amore sto cazzo
guglielmo invece scusa eh se per caso
dovessi guardare questo video ne dublino
ma comunque mi puoi venire a spiegare
come a casa se voti quando l'indirizzo
suoni ci facciamo un caffettino quel che
vuoi
cosa c'è ke fai tu durante il 140 sì
sarei stato quattro volte 4 dove di
tutto una decina di battute al massimo
potevo sostituirti col cadavere di mia
nonna dante uguale a dispetto di quello
che dica la gente a me piacciono i tuoi
video ho fatto partire una campagna per
l'abolizione delle parrucche su youtube
cioè viene nulla togliere a chi lo fa e
video con le parrucche però c'è stato un
periodo dell'anno scorso che se youtube
sembrava un bordello di chicago prima di
travestiti
mancava solo il pappone o breve su con
il pastore con il teschio i denti d'oro
per che camminasse per youtube ma vada
di quello progetto fai dei film forse un
bene che tu non abbia fatto niente ma io
spero che in corteo tu sappia perché che
hanno ficcato in quel film che hanno
fatto di le quattro rom in un'ora e
quaranta semplicemente per riempire le
sale di ragazzine piccolissime che una
volta visto il film vanno nei bagni del
cinema sgrillettarvi e paolo ruffini che
cazzo fa paolo ruffini presenta colorado
ma l'afa è pronto mi stavo dimenticando
c'è un bellissimo cameo di pino la
lavatrice che fa pino la lavatrice in
università ad oxford
ok beh spero che ti abbiano pagato bene
probabilmente a qualcuno di voi questo
film potrà piacere e fa benissimo così e
il punto è che ormai non si centra più
il bersaglio di cosa voglia dire fare un
film comico questo film qua in
particolare non fa ridere
perché non è verosimile
ci sono film comici e film comici ma
secondo me ci vuole comunque la
distinzione fra quello che potrebbe
essere verosimile e quello che invece
fin troppo il realistico anche in un
film comico
mi spiego una pallottola spuntata una
pallottola spuntata e palesemente
tendenziale se tu a un certo punto vedi
in questo che tecnicamente è un
poliziesco un dinosauro che passa nello
sfondo sicuramente avrà un qualche
significato e torno ti stupisci dicendo
oh mio dio una pallottola spuntata un
film di merda perché c'è un dinosauro
nello sfondo probabilmente appunto avrà
un qualche significato lo spettatore ha
capito che un film demenziale e quindi
non si stupisce e riesce a ridere della
battuta invece dall'altra parte troviamo
i film di aldo giovanni e giacomo
difende aldo giovanni giacomo sono
verosimili nel senso che tutto quello
che succede potrebbe tranquillamente
succedere in ambito all reale diciamo sì
quindi la risata delle battute sarà il
fatto che potrebbero succedere a
chiunque lo spettatore potrebbe
rispecchiarsi nelle situazioni che ci
sono nel film perché sono verosimili
fuga di cervelli e nel mezzo c'è nel
posto più sbagliato dove potrebbe essere
un film comico perché non è demenziale
però succedono cose troppe inverosimili
perso un film realistico quindi tutto
quello che succede e fuori contesto e
non scatta la risata nello spettatore
quindi la mia domanda era paolo ruffini
ha inventato trovato un'altra vocazione
che non sia il regista visto che questa
vocazione l'hai fatta a partire da
fondata con il primo film che hai fatto
giusto per sapere d'amico tutti e due
non è divertente non è divertente e
soprattutto non è divertente ripete un
area che quella filosofia da due soldi
che di solito random il film la nostra
filosofia consiste nel far casino dalla
mattina alla sera e poi alla fine di
tutto quanto riuscire comunque
rimorchiare è questo ragazzini è un
insegnamento per tutti voi a youtube
io voglio sempre tenere
sul cervello quando guarda il film
voglio anche guardare qualche film che
me lo faccia spegnere e ti do ragione io
sono un grande fan dei film di jason
statham per esempio ma sapete qual è il
problema del cinema italiano in questo
momento è che non ci sono alternative
quindi chiedo scusa se arriva al film
fatto dal web cioè quella che dovrebbe
essere l'alternativa la televisione e
poi è ancora peggio di quella che è la
televisione
ce lo scudo forse non lo spento
abbastanza cervello e poi io mi chiedo
ingenuamente perché la gente non riesca
a prendere youtube sul serio da fuori
salve salverebbero qual è il problema è
che non importa quanto sia brutto il
film l'importante è che faccia soldi e
sefik in un film gente come frank matano
e uil bush che hanno milionate di views
i soldi arrivano quindi teoricamente io
sto parlando male di un successo al
botteghino quindi ragazzina che sei
riuscita a smettere di masturbarsi in
bagno per venire a scrivere un commento
negativo su di me che sto parlando male
dei tuoi idoli
vai a vedere il film passerà in un'ora e
quaranta che non dimenticherai mai